foreign
I had just moved Halfway Around the
World
to get my masters in international
Affairs at Ching Hua
China's top university
but I didn't care about International
affairs
no I was there for doors
you see China is a tier one market
and I knew that the experience and
connections I made there would open lots
of doors
up to that point in my career everything
had been of Outdoors every job I took
every event I attended every program I
applied to was about how many doors it
would open
and China
was one big door
the first week of the program
I was sitting in my building's Lobby
it was a Lobby unlike any I had ever
seen
and that Lobby could only be entered
through two beautiful doors
each one must have been 20 feet tall by
five feet wide and heavy to the touch
it was like it had been carved from an
oak tree and placed directly on the
hinges of the building
as I studied their beauty one of my
classmates walked through those doors
and changed my life forever
when he walked through something was
different
he stood a little bit taller
he held his chin up a tad bit higher and
he walked with a bit more swag in his
step
I immediately spotted the reason why
these were all symptoms of a fresh
haircut
I studied and admired his perfection
the sides they were Blended seamlessly
and his hairline was so crisp that you
might even have called it cold
but I wasn't the only one that noticed
that evening at dinner he was surrounded
by black classmates who had to know
exactly where he had been
we had to know where he had been because
for black men the barber shop is not
just a place you go to get your hair cut
in a world we are constantly facing
Prejudice bias and discrimination
because of the color of our skin the
barber shop is a safe haven
it's a place where you can be
exist without the mental and emotional
pressure of that reality
and the haircut
the haircut becomes the ultimate Act of
self-care
I made my appointment for the very next
day and after my last class hopped on my
bike and headed over
I had the butterflies associated with
the first date
what if I didn't like him or he didn't
like me
what if his shop was dirty or he messed
up my hair
the questions were endless because I
needed to find my Barbershop
carrying the weight of these
expectations I parked my bike and opened
the front door
I was met by a row of Chinese women
styling hair
confused I stopped and prepared to
double check my address but before I
could The frontmost Stylist looked up
and without saying a word pointed to the
back of the shop
she knew exactly why I was there
I maneuvered down the long narrow shop
and reached into the hallway and pulled
back a curtain and saw the validation
that I had needed
my new Barber was finishing up another
client
he had a straight razor in his hand and
was zoomed in close
and with a touch so gentle so as to
remove a single strand of hair he gently
edged his hairline
next he leaned back and placed two
fingers on his Temple
and checked each side
like an artist making sure his canvas
was just perfect
I knew that I had found my barber
over the next few months I went to that
barber shop at least once a week
sometimes twice really any time I needed
a moment of reprieve from the challenges
of being both black and foreign in China
as I got closer with my barber he said
he wanted to expand and look to me for
investment
I really believed in him and wanted to
shop to exceed so I weighed the pros and
cons and I ran the numbers but as much
as I wanted to I just couldn't do it
it wasn't a nice enough door
it wasn't prestigious or important
enough to make anyone prestigious or
important care
so I closed that door
leaving behind What mattered to me to
continue pursuing What mattered more to
others
soon thereafter covet ended my time in
China
and I ended up on a gaming team at a big
tech company in Silicon Valley
it was a fast growing and high profile
role that I knew was going to accelerate
my career
where I could begin to access those far
more prestigious stories that I was so
desperate to achieve
but I didn't care about gaming or the
company
and as I wrapped up my onboarding and
met my new team I had the same question
that I had my first week in China
what am I doing here
next as I struggled to answer this
question everything would change on May
25th 2020.
I remember sitting at home and watching
the video of George Floyd's murder over
and over again
I couldn't help but think how powerless
he must have felt to be slowly strangled
to death by people watched and recorded
as he called out for his mother
it made me question everything
and after weeks of reflection I was left
one very simple question
was I Living For my resume
or for my eulogy
I went for a run around downtown Oakland
and happened to see one of my old
Barbers it was the early days of the
pandemic and all the barber shops were
closed so he had the great idea to bring
his shop to the street
he had parked his old beat up Fort Pinto
in a fire lane along a busy corridor
out of the cracked back window an orange
extension cord snaked down the sidewalk
to a small patch of grass where he stood
behind a navy blue plastic chair with a
pair of Clippers by his feet
it wasn't the prettiest setup but I
hadn't had a haircut in weeks so I was
excited to hop in the chair
I wasn't expecting much from it but the
moment the Clippers graze my head I felt
instant relief
it didn't have any familiar sights
sounds or smells of the barbershop I was
used to no pictures of Muhammad Ali
Malcolm X no rapper r b music playing in
the background no soft sweet smell of
barbicide
but it was a barbershop nonetheless
it was about my relationship with my
barber
it was about being cared for
I realize how much the barbershop meant
to me that whether it was in the back of
a woman's Salon in Beijing or in the
middle of a public park in downtown
Oakland every time I walk through those
doors my soul was nourished
and it was there during that cold and
windy haircut in the park that my answer
had found me
the barbershop it hadn't just closed for
me it had clothes for all black men
denying us a safe haven at a time when
we needed it most
I decided that I was going to reopen
that door by starting a mobile barber
shop
inspired I got to work conducted
industry research and prototyped an app
I interviewed customers and talked to
Barbers that were ready to get back to
work
and then the moment of truth I needed to
purchase the van
I went to the dealership for a test
drive and it was perfect
but I I was petrified
it would cost a hundred and fifty
thousand dollars to purchase and convert
the van and I knew that the moment I
signed there would be no going back
the fear
the uncertainty
the doubt
it wasn't mobilizing
I didn't know anything about cutting air
I'd never run a business I didn't even
know where I could legally park it
but most of all
I think I figured who I would be if I
failed
I would no longer be Tere the
up-and-coming young techie on his way to
Doing Great Things No I would be Tere
the failure who had wasted his potential
and opportunity on a barber shop
but I had decided I was done chasing
doors
I remember closing my eyes
taking a deep breath
and signing my name
all the questions and uncertainty remain
but the fear it evaporated
I was fully committed now and the only
way forward was to get to work
I made a to-do list find a parking lot
check
build a website handle hire a carpenter
done
after a few weeks I had converted the
van acquired some customers and actually
started a business
the next two years were a crash course
in entrepreneurship and life
I had some truly satisfying highs and
some surprisingly miserable lows
in the end the business failed
and I lost every dime that I put into it
but in the process I gained something
much more valuable
that was freedom
to stop chasing doors
to be successful
we've all had to chase some doors
there's nothing wrong with it
and sometimes it's required
the problem arises when we Chase doors
for the sake of the chase
because chasing doors well it's
addictive
our friends and family congratulate us
and they push us to open the next one
we feel a sense of Pride and
accomplishment in our achievement
like followers on Tick Tock are likes on
Instagram the dopamine of opening that
next door is so much more appealing than
the fear and uncertainty of closing one
so we wait
we tell ourselves we'll open our door
later when we have enough money or
enough experience
we defer our dreams because that door it
leads to the deepest part of our souls
to a place that we're often too afraid
to venture
we're afraid that we won't be able to
handle it
we're afraid that we won't like what we
find there
we're afraid of who we might be if we
fail
but the truth is
when you open that door
that big and scary one that sets your
heart on fire
you unlock a new part of your soul that
gives you everything you need to find
your way
so ask yourself
what door has your name on it
and are you willing to open it
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign